the ukraine crisis threatens to drive
gasoline prices even higher in the u.s
russia is one of the world's top
suppliers of oil and natural gas
especially in europe the conflict has
pushed world oil prices above 100 a
borough that's the highest in eight
years russia and ukraine are also the
world's largest wheat producers now the
u.s does not import wheat from russia
but millions rely on that supply haleema
croth is with us right now she is
managing director and global head of
commodity strategy at rbc capital
markets how you doing good morning good
morning thank you for joining us now
here in the u.s we're dealing with
inflation rising gas prices now could
russia's actions in ukraine have an
effect on us at the gas pump absolutely
i mean russia is a global commodity
superstore they produce so many of the
commodities that we need on a daily
basis and we've already had a very tight
oil market we have this global economic
reopening people are getting in their
cars they're getting on airplanes and
the oil suppliers are basically some of
them are withholding supply and we may
not have enough supply out there if
demand continues to grow so we're
already concerned about the situation
and now we have an active conflict
involving one of the world's largest
producers so there's real concern that
if russia were to withhold energy
supplies we could see much higher prices
at the pump helena uh on a day like this
we have all hands on deck so gail is in
los angeles she woke up bright and early
and she has a question for you as well
yes halima hello hello you know on the
way here we noticed that the gas prices
was was ranging from 509 to 538 yowza
that's very high i asked the driver what
was it last week last week it was four
something so it in in a week's time it's
jumped very significantly is there
nothing that the u.s could do to produce
more more gas more oil here
that's a great question gail i mean we
are such a large producer but u.s
production has fallen back from the
highs that we saw in 2019 we had this
major collapse in prices in 2020
many companies cut production and we
also situation where u.s investors have
wanted u.s oil and gas companies to
basically return profits to shareholders
not put it into the ground so u.s
production is growing but it's not
growing at the pace that it used to grow
so if we need more oil quickly gail
where we have to do is we have to ask
countries like saudi arabia for more oil
we've had u.s officials visiting the
kingdom i was there last week and
they've been asking the saudis to pump
more we also have strategic stockpiles
of oil that we can use in emergencies
and we are likely to tap those
stockpiles to try to put more oil on
this market and bring down prices
do you think nancy quarters says oh i'm
sorry gail do you want to follow up no
no no i was just going to say do you
think that the prices will continue to
climb here
i mean gail we really have to watch the
situation unfold because there's real
concern that as we impose more economic
sanctions on vladimir putin on the
russian state that they may weaponize
commodity exports essentially withhold
supplies to try to make us feel the pain
of our actions and see how much we're
willing to defend ukraine halima we
don't have a ton of time but we saw
nancy's piece that parliament member in
ukraine begging for action to cut russia
off from swift which is a system that
allows banks to lend to transfer money
why aren't we doing that i mean that is
really because a number of european
countries don't want to take that step
yet european nations particularly italy
germany are much more economically tied
to russia and so they want a more
moderate ratcheting up of sanctions that
said though if the situation does
deteriorate i think swift will be back
on the table helena croft thank you for
joining us thank you for having me of
course